The example we're looking at here, is an
automobile info box, in particular for the Tesla Model
S. In this lesson, we're going to use info
box data throughout our examples, involving Mongo DB. So,
let's take a look at the data that's
represented in this info box. Manufacturer, we have production
years, model years. Several different assembly plants, a designer,
class, body style, with 2 elements, 5 door and
liftback, and a number of other fields. So what
I'd like to do here, is talk about how
we might model this data in MongoDB, as documents
using the JSON like syntax I mentioned earlier. So in
modeling this data, let's start with some of the
scalar valued fields that are here. Here we can see
scalar fields for manufacturer, class, and body style. We
can also model a couple of array fields here for
production, model years, and layout. So here,
in our Json like syntax, for MongoDB, we've
modeled that same data, using array value fields.
Now, we could model the designer field, as
just a single string. But to show an alternative, we might also model it as
a simple person document, as follows. And here
we have a document with a designer field
that has a nested document within it, for the
designer. And last, putting the idea of array fields
and embedded documents together. We might represent the assembly
data in this example, like this, with an assembly
field that has an array, containing embedded documents for
each of the assembly plants. So, in Mango DB,
our entire document for the Tesla Model S might
look something like this. With a mixture of fields that
are scalars, array valued and embedded documents. One
of the many cool things about this, is that
Mongo DB natively supports a very common big
data format, that being JSON. And by support I
mean, that we can store data items structured
this way in our database and do queries that
would say, for example, identify all documents where the
city of assembly is Fremont. Driving down the hierarchy,
to actually pull out matches for this piece of data,
even though it's nested several layers deep within an individual document.